the gyro can experience so what are you
telling them to think of when you're
telling them like we teach in combat
pistols and you teach them how to
utilize a pistol what do you what is the
process of like I try and break stuff
down as simple as possible so that it's
easy steps for people to talk through to
create a habit so that you're using it
as a subconscious effort right like I
want you to be able to draw and fire
that pistol or shoulder and fire the
rifle in a way that you're almost not
thinking through once you become very
proficient at the shooting so that your
brain can stay open to all the other
pertinent [ __ ] that's going on all the
scary crap that's happening out there
right so it becomes an automatic yeah
but you want it to be like that you want
it to be an automatic movement and
there's guys out there with a [ __ ] ton
more combat time and a [ __ ] ton more
teaching experience that say the exact
same thing and they say it because it
works because there's not time to screw
around with having to think through the
process it's similar to how you're
drawing a bone hunting right give time
to really think through it all not with
an animal walking out in front of you
know you have to already had that stuff
it's gotta be dialed in yeah yeah super
dialed so with pistol and rifle it's the
same way like I'm gonna break that down
so simple and we can only handle so much
information so I'll break it down real
simple and then feed you more pieces
individually as they come up
now how much in the military how much
time do they spend instructing or
coaching people on how to how to think
during intense and stressful situations
so they stomp they started to do more of
that when I was in buds so it's a fairly
recent thing relatively recent and I
know they do more now and what they're
trying to do is get people to make sure
that they can understand what they're
doing
and perform under the pressure right and
a lot of a lot of the training in a lot
of the selection weeds out people that
can't put stress and information into
the same lane of traffic mm-hmm right
all right okay so that's what a lot of
what buds is yeah yeah a lot of buds and
sqt and then further on and the teams
like every day you're earning your
tridon is what they say you can always
lose it so what they're what they're
saying is like it's all processed but
they've been they're weeding people out
that can't handle that sort of [ __ ]
mm-hmm and so does this something that
they've written books on are there
manuals on this and or is this just
something that's understood and known I
don't remember there being manuals on
this for me when I was in like a
psychological stuff mm-hmm
we did have some guys come in and talk
to us and then what kind of advice would
they give you oh god you know I don't
particularly remember exactly what the
advice was like word for word but I do
remember it being like follow your
training you know we're training you the
right way and it's not the do as you're
told
yes do what you know how to do right and
you'll do it well and is a lot of being
able to perform in combat in these
situations that are insanely stressful
and to be able to manage information and
stress at the same time he's a lot of
that just learned by experience I think
so what was it like for you being
overseas or the process yeah well I was
one of the youngest guys there because I
was augmenting meaning I was an extra
person I volunteered to go ask to go so
I was open ears open eyes and closed
mouth for four months like these dudes
that are over there
have been had been doing it for a long
time at that point because I was there
in 2011 and 12 and it's all a process
that is fatally consequential and I knew
that so you're like I'm just gonna shut
up and [ __ ] listen
or shut up and watch that's wise it's
[ __ ] terrifying is why it's not
necessarily being wise like you just I
don't want to die yeah like if that
dude's stepping over there for a reason
you know he's not leaning against that
wall for a reason he's doing this for a
reason he's got his gear set up like
that for it's not for fun you know
they're not over there airsofting it's
[ __ ] for real so you ask questions
and the best thing that I've been able
to get from the teams which was super
evident there as you learn how to learn
you know you learn how to be a student a
good one because if you're not there's a
good chance you could die a lot of guys
have died overseas and a lot of guys
have died in training it's still doing
the right thing
[Applause]